the US is reportedly removing Patriot
anti-missile systems and other military
assets from Saudi Arabia as it winds
down a military buildup that began as
tensions with Iran flared up last year
this is all coming from The Wall Street
Journal among the facilities affected
will be Saudi oil installations remember
the u.s. deployed more assets there
after an attack on Saudi Aramco oil
plants last September dozens of US
military personnel will also be
reassigned
well when asked about the report
President Donald Trump would not be
drawn on specifics well I don't want to
talk about it but we're doing some
things will make it a lot of moves in
the Middle East and elsewhere we're
doing a lot of things all over the world
militarily we've been taking advantage
of all over the world our military and
in the sense that we're and this is
nothing to do with Saudi Arabia this has
to do with other countries frankly much
more we have the most powerful military
in the world we've spent 1.5 trillion
dollars since I've been here more than
that 1.5 trillion dollars on a military
that we now have the strongest military
we've ever had we have the best
equipment the best missiles planes the
best of everything
we're authorizing and just authorized
ships new ships being built they're all
being built in the United States and
they're beauties is we have the best
submarines in the world by far and we
have submarines being built and we go
around and protect other countries and
other countries don't respect us like
they should in some cases they don't
even like us and those days are over
those days are over so things are moving
and I'm not putting Sony on that thing
but we are doing certain things that
will be positive for us and I think very
positive for them too we've got Samuel
Dramani with us now Middle East analyst
and regular contributor to The
Washington Post and foreign policy on
Scott from Toronto to there Sam whoo
nice to have you with us
again the president there apparently not
talking about it but still obviously
talking about how strong he perceives
the US military to be if there is a
drawdown in Saudi Arabia what's your
read on it
through the drawdown is largely related
to the ongoing side of the oil price war
with russia which is indirectly related
to US shale gas over the past several
weeks isn't a lot of pressure and
heating for Republicans and first we
usually pro savvy on trumpeting stronger
action against Saudi Arabia on this
issue obviously secondary factors could
be the US need to redeploy more
resources towards the Asia Pacific
region that's the adventures of lately
China and also the belief that Iran is
on something of a back foot as position
in Syria has receded drew Israeli
airstrikes it's a military forces in
Iraq begin to fracture and also deals
with the combined impact of Cova
nineteen it sanctions but I would rate
the oil rights war as a primary factor
and then usually China and the weakness
of Iran a secondary and tertiary factors
respectively in this new decision does
it speak to any fracture in the us-saudi
relationship obviously not a major one
but still between the views of Congress
and the White House on Saudi Arabia so
throughout 2018-2019 Busan gradual
increase in Congress members full
demoknights and Republicans Lindsey
Graham in particular criticizing the
Saudi war in Yemen which a product
junkie uses presidential veto when
Congress would normally be perving that
after the Khashoggi murder in October
2018 we saw further spike in discord
Saudi Arabia so but the White House
contained you dependent so now I think
even though Trump is not listed a thank
you give me my name and saying it's what
many other countries this is a
realignment between the White House and
the executive legislative branches on
Honoria and I guess we also perhaps
shouldn't read it as a complete cooling
on the idea of any conflict in Iran
because well Congress passed a bill
which would have limited Donald Trump's
ability to attack Iran but he's gone and
vetoed that anyway so that still hangs
over everything it feels like because
there's hewmet of Joe Biden where to win
in November they be able to reestablish
a modified version
the jcpoa coming back into order so they
certainly have a clear interest in not
allowing that to happen I think there is
a grave risk of a confrontation with
Iran still I'm a member just as recently
as a little over a month ago there was
the attack on British and American
forces in Iraq but continued Iranian
used to make incursions into northern
Yemen which lead to missile strikes into
Saudi Arabia yeah we the thing possible
and they could draw in US forces so Iraq
and yeah Yemen Saudi border I mean
potential areas of friction where the
u.s. can be dragged in so I think that
trumpet doesn't want to have to be tied
in blood reaction with Iran but the same
time you want send a strong message that
Saudi Arabia needs to comply on the oil
issue oil production may be restricted
in the near future it's a bit of a
burning tool rather than a complete
overall strategy so miramanee always a
pleasure talking to you thanks for
joining us I think you're right